once this wild cape Paris is back to
full health
she'll be released she's been suffering
from silicon beak and feather disease
conservation biologist Steve Bois runs a
project to save the Cape from extinction
and rebuild its populations there are
only a thousand left in the wild beak
and feather disease is highly contagious
and represents a mortal danger to the
species when this bird was first brought
in she was in a very bad way she was she
was in an awful condition I'm surprised
that she saw that that she survived and
that she's progressed as well as she has
it's to me it's absolute revelation the
virus makes the feathers fall off and
the beak develop lesions this patient
could no longer fly and was stuck on the
branch of a tree when boys and his team
came to the rescue
she remained in poor health for a year
and a half then boys started to feed her
and some other sick birds the species
favorite traditional food the fruit of
the yellow wood tree as soon as we
started feeding them yellow wood fruits
after trying everything we started to
see the virus go down in their blood so
far that we couldn't even find it until
we used a new technique and found it at
very low levels so this is the medicine
for care parents that is missing from
their diet so it's not just wonderful
nutrition it is a medicine for them
researchers here in Cape Town are also
considering what affects climate changes
having or could have on bird populations
how will vegetation and animal
populations react if temperatures rise
and rainfall drops Germany's Development
Agency GI Z is supporting the research
you would need I would say at least
another two degrees of temperature
change and in the region of a five to
ten percent reduction
in rainfall you know if you're looking
at that kind of a scenario that I would
think is it's going to start having an
adverse effect on everyone 10 for us
continuous forest used to stretch across
the Cape region rich in indigenous
species such as the yellow wood now
there are just a few separate patches of
forest left on large plantations foreign
species prevail if they're forest
habitats are further reduced the cape
parrots might be wiped out their food of
choice is already hard to find because
countless yellow wood trees once very
abundant have been felled this fine
specimen is 1,000 years old the forests
were full of mature yellow woods until
the commercial loggers came yellow wood
trees and now rare and their fruits as
well
for centuries now their timber has been
much in demand yellow words were part of
the Industrial Revolution in South
Africa millions of these trees were
removed for railway sleepers and mining
timber descended underground but today
yellow wood because of its beautiful
color is one of the most valuable
Timbers on earth now in some places this
will sell for as much as three thousand
euros per cubic metre a mature tree
fetches twenty-five to thirty thousand
euros although the government has set
limits on the number of trees that may
be felled illegal logging continues as
you can see with the sawdust still here
this is very recently logged the leaves
are still alive everything in epic an ax
piece still alive so this was in the
last week we have now lost another two
hundred year old two hundred and fifty
year old yellow wood tree one of very
few remaining but this carries on each
year one tree after another until we one
day have no old yellow its remaining go
yellow wood fruit may be the perfect
food and contain an antiviral agent it's
now scarce and the birds have turned to
acorns and pecans but they contain
toxins and too much fat and sugar
a century ago yellow would fruits were
available throughout the year now
between January and March the parrots
have nothing to eat weakened birds are
more susceptible to disease the
situation may not be entirely bleak
though boys couldn't spot any chicks for
five years it's only healthy cape
parents that reproduce and these two
look like they might be about to do just
that cape parrots need cavities to breed
in but suitable natural cavities are in
short supply now so the cape parrot
project has put up hundreds of nesting
boxes Steve Boyce checks to see if
they're in good condition and can keep
out the rain the project is also
planning to reforest large stretches of
land with yellow wood trees then the
parent will once again have their
perfect food the year round the cape
parrot project pays villagers to tend
seedlings of yellow wood and other
indigenous species about 1 euro per tree
and more money to look after them later
this is one of the poorest regions in
South Africa the project offers a
welcome source of additional income this
project is very good for us as a
community because when
we get money out of this project we buy
feels like chairs and ties make the
community all different in this one
Valley 10,000 trees have already been
planted there should be a million more
to come our education with the local
people would have them taking care of
those trees for the next 25 years for
the next hundred years as these forests
grow up and big again that's that's what
we're looking to do is keep this growing
establish ourselves 100 miles to the
north all the way down this mountain
range so that if we do this with all the
communities maybe 50 communities by the
end so this is a big idea
all for one parrot we need to restore
everything we've done especially to the
forests of the world the lens of our
planet
you